[Music]
thank you so much I'm really happy to be
here I love Amsterdam
I know we're all probably looking
forward to dinner so I will I will try
to be brief but also there is gonna be
code on the on the screen so if you want
to move forward that's what I would
recommend but also if you don't if you
aren't able to see anything just come
find me after and I have some examples
that I can that I can give to you okay
so in a previous job than the one that I
have now I was working as a data
scientist at a nonprofit that built
software for caseworkers in child
welfare and we were looking at the data
and we noticed that we had some children
in the data that were older than their
parents and not only were they older
than their parents they were like a lot
older than their parents and they were
like a lot older than everyone and once
we started looking at you know the the
distribution of Ages and we started
looking at the birth dates it was pretty
easy to figure out what had happened so
there was a bug in the software that my
company was building such that if you
entered the birth year information as
two digits instead of four we would only
store those two digits and we wouldn't
prepend the century information on so if
a caseworker is entering information
about a child born in the year 2008 and
they enter it as Oh 8 he would claim
that that child was born in the year 8
ad so everyone everyone that works with
data has stories like this we have
assumptions about the data but our
assumptions don't hold and so what were
my assumptions in this in this story the
first is that children are born after
their parents and the second is that
there's an upper limit to how old a
person can live
and I had sort of like a kind of vague
upper limit for myself but when I was
writing this talk I was actually curious
about like what's the longest someone
has ever lived and it turns out that the
longest confirmed human lifespan is over
a hundred and twenty-two years this
person is no longer living but if you if
you look at the Wikipedia page for like
longest confirmed lifespans of the top
ten one of them is still alive so what
are some other assumptions that we
generally have about data one of the big
ones is that all of the data are there
there's no missing data another might be
that the records are unique there aren't
there aren't any duplicates one that was
definitely important to us when I was
working with the software company was is
there any personally identifiable
information things like Social Security
numbers and this is like obviously not
an exhaustive list and so this this sort
of poses a really important question
which is how do we make sure that our
assumptions are valid all right so how
is it fair for me to assume that
children should have birth dates after
their parents and the second one is how
do I make sure that my assumptions are
being met and the reason that we need to
answer these two questions is because we
don't just collect data to have it right
like we we have data around in order to
make decisions to change processes to
pick different workflows so in this
example age is a really important
attribute when caseworkers are making
decisions about what options they have
for a child and so another thing and I
was talking to Yanis about this last
night this was not originally in my talk
but we had such a good conversation
about it that I wanted to bring it up as
well is that we all know that that data
collection is is very very brittle right
so you can introduce a change into a
data set and it'll just like your entire
ETL pipeline is just going to come like
crashing down around your ears
and you're gonna have to rewrite the
whole thing to work with the new data
and you're gonna do this all the time
and so those kinds of those kinds of
data failures when the data sort of
don't meet your assumptions they're kind
of they're kind of nice in a way because
they're loud and you can find them and
they break stuff so they don't make it
all the way through into your
application or they don't I I now work
for two Sigma investments they don't
make it all the way through into a live
trading model but there are also all
kinds of assumptions we have about data
that if those aren't being met they sort
of sneak right by they don't break
things good examples of these are you
know what if the failure that you have
is that the data set didn't even show up
so it didn't even kick off a process
that could have then fallen over and so
what I'm going to talk to you about
today is how can we extend the software
methodology of unit testing to data to
try to make our assumptions about data
explicit to get in the habit as people
that work with data of validating our
assumptions and to give us confidence
that our assumptions are being met so
I'm Jane I work at 2 Sigma investments
in New York and I like really don't want
to be the person that gets up in front
of a group of people and like recites my
company's mission statement but my
company's mission statement is to find
value in the world's data and so in
order to do this one we have to bring in
all of the world's data we're very good
at that and we need to make sure that
all of our assumptions about that data
we need to make sure that those
assumptions are rock-solid that they're
motivated and we need to make sure that
they're being met and we need to do this
for thousands of data sets and thousands
of diverse data sets so what does this
look like just for one data set so
usually we start by like reading the
documentation if there is any and we
start by exploring and analyzing the
data and and we're you know either
explicitly or implicitly we're
developing a set
of assumptions about how these data
should behave and this is expensive it
takes time and it also takes domain
expertise so in a in a talk earlier we
were looking at MRI images I have very
very little experience with with image
data personally so it's gonna be
difficult for you know without that
domain expertise for me to come up with
a set of well-motivated
assumptions about that kind of data so
we might need to hire someone else
that's better at that than me and also
while we're doing this while we're sort
of exploring and analyzing the data
while we're sort of looking at the
schema and looking at the data and
looking at the metadata and then looking
at the data and saying okay you know was
it fair for me to assume that children
should have birth dates after their
parents and often the documentation is
really shoddy so there are many
conversations with your data vendor
about ok like well what is like what's
actually in here and then when you're
all done you should write all that stuff
down and so now you get a gold star
right you've been you've been explicit
about your assumptions you've validated
that they hold for your data set and
seriously you wrote it down
like seriously write this stuff down but
what if the data change so data are
always changing one really classic
example one really classic way that data
change is just that you get more so it's
like the next month's worth of data from
this data vendor but you also have to
deal with things like collection
technologies or processes being upgraded
you you deal with questions being added
to and removed from surveys and you also
deal with things like panels like grow
and change over time and so how do you
know that your assumptions are still
valid and like how do you know that
they're still being met so like if you
didn't write down your assumption like
that's on you like your own you're your
own worst enemy but if you did write
your assumptions down that's great
because you can go back to that list and
you can say okay this is what I
you know this is what I decided on it
first I'm gonna look at my new data set
and I'm gonna say okay do all of these
things still hold but this really
doesn't scale so one problem could be
that like the data are just too big or
they arrive too frequently for you to
sort of do this like okay here are my
assumptions I'm gonna check the data
here are my assumptions I'm gonna check
the data but another problem is that
what if you're responsible for managing
more than that just like that one data
set but you have tens hundreds even
thousands of data sets that you're
actually personally responsible for
stewarding and like what if you go on
vacation or switch teams or in a more
severe example that we were talking
about last night like what if you're
hospitalized and you really can't be
reached and someone has to deal with the
data that are coming in so what we're
really what we really want we want we
want something that's sort of like set
it and forget it we want somewhere to
write our assumptions down we want that
place to evaluate our assumptions for us
and we want it to tell us when those
assumptions aren't being met and so we
sort of realized this problem and I was
sort of like you know like hey like unit
test is a really good existing framework
that solves a lot of these these
problems that I have
and it has a couple of advantages and I
can talk more about why we picked unit
tests specifically all of the examples
in this talk by the way are going to be
Python unit tests there are other
testing libraries in Python and if you
want to talk about why we picked unit
tests over PI tests for example um just
come find me after and we can have a
lively debate um anyway so so some of
the things also I apologize for the
browser bar at the top we could just not
figure out how to get that to go away
anyway so so one of some things we liked
about unit test is it's it's flexible so
it allows us to implement a bunch of
different testing strategies so one of
the things that's similar between
data like a data set and a code base is
that in the same way that you can't test
two code bases in the same way you'll
have a really hard time effectively
testing two data sets in the same way
and I like to joke you know like if we
could test these data sets the same way
why are we paying for them both the
other the thing that we really liked is
that it's it's kind of its batteries
included so there's a test runner it
will automatically sort of catch
failures and errors for me and it will
aggregate them into a digest that that I
can read right so it was important to us
not to roll our own we wanted to use the
tools that were all already developed
already supported and lastly unit
testing is it's a repeatable and it's an
automated process so one of the problems
if we were sort of manually reasserting
our assumptions on the data set is that
you know that's it's inconsistent and
it's an it's error-prone so what does it
actually look like when we try to write
a unit test for data so again if you're
in the back I really apologize if you
can't see this I will walk through I
will walk through every piece of this
so the first how many of you are you
familiar with unit test amazing so this
should look very familiar to you I'm
gonna talk through it pretty explicitly
for the people that aren't familiar so
the first part so this is a this is a
test case class and these first two
methods are just my test my setup in my
teardown and I made some fake data to
purposefully make these fail but in the
setup I'm basically loading my data I
could be loading it from everywhere it
could be from anywhere I could be
reading it from HDFS it could be a
sequel query I could be hitting an HTTP
endpoint and then in the teardown I'm
like taking the data off my test case so
that every single test method gets a
fresh copy which is really important you
don't want to your test methods to
pollute each other in any way and so I
wrote two test methods for the two
assumptions that I named earlier the
first is that children are their birth
are after their parents birth dates and
so DF here is a panda's data frame that
this might be a confusing expression to
people that aren't familiar with pandas
but basically what I'm saying is I'm I'm
making like a boolean mask that says
okay for every row in my data frame just
is the child's birth date after the
parents birth date and that I'm making
sure that that in like every sort of
element in that series is true we're
good and this second test here which I
had a very difficult time coming up with
a name for and I was very proud of what
I came up with but does everyone know
who Methuselah is No okay my face will
live for like 900 years or something
like that
he's like a piece of biblical figure so
what I did in this test is I take that
that longest confirm lifespan 122 years
and 163 days and I said okay if you
lived that long as if you were that old
today when would you have to be born and
then I compared all of the parents
birthday or I compared the minimum
parent birthdate and the minimum child
birth date to that like earliest
possible birth date and so if we run
this we'll get failure messages like
these and again I made them I made them
fail on purpose
and so this is useful because I've I've
written my my two assumptions down right
now
I can run this test case every time I
get new data and if weird birth dates
are ever delivered my tests are gonna
fail and I'll know that something is
wrong and so this seems great but when
you try to do this like a couple of
interesting challenges and interesting
differences crop up and so the first is
that unit testing as an approach assumes
that there's a clear-cut pass/fail that
you can evaluate and our assumptions
about data just aren't always a
clear-cut pass/fail and the second is
that you know software unit tests
usually fail as you are literally making
changes to the code and that's not
usually the scenario in which data unit
tests fail and finally getting a data
unit test passing isn't only about like
fixing the data there's there's more
that's involved so to dig into these
challenges a little bit so for example
for children that are Oh for children
that are older than their parents I
might say okay yeah that's always a
failure that's like a pretty unambiguous
like that should never happen but for
people that are really old it's a bit
different like I might care about the
difference between being you know one
day older than the longest confirmed
lifespan versus a hundred years longer
than the oldest confirmed lifespan or I
also might care about like the
distribution of Ages or I might care
okay how many bad birth dates do I have
and the second challenge is that tests
usually don't fail because of changes
that you made right so again software
unit tests usually fail as a result of a
change you just made to the code and
there's so what that means is that
there's a good chance that you have
context on what caused to the failure
but data unit tests often fail as the
result of changes made upstream and
these can be perhaps even outside of
your organization so they can be changes
that the data vendor made and are
completely opaque to you and that means
that you might have zero context on what
caused the failure and finally getting a
data unit test passing isn't just about
fixing the data so another another sort
of assumption that we have about data
that I mentioned earlier is that there
is no PII in the data set so this is a
little test method with the over-the-top
social security number regex match
pattern from this great article it
really does not fit onto one line
it this over-the-top one not only
excludes social security numbers that
are actually like malformed but it also
takes out like a common sort of dupes or
fakes and so then I say okay for every
for every column in my data frame and
for every cell in that column I just
want to make sure that there's not a
Social Security number records match and
so again I made this test fail I'm gonna
get a failure like we see here and I
could get my test I could get my data
unit test passing again by removing the
social security numbers from the data
set but that's not necessarily the right
thing to do the right thing to do might
be to call the data vendor and be like
what the heck like you can't be sending
us Social Security numbers or it might
be to go talk to the developers or data
engineers and say like hey like we
really need to be hashing or encrypting
these social security numbers and you
know how are you supposed to know that
you're supposed to do either of those
things and so with these three sort of
challenges have in common
is that the problem is that context is
really expensive to recover in this
context includes you know why is this
test here what caused this failure and
like really what am I supposed to do
about it
so to go to go back to our Methuselah
example you know we can see that 1894 12
5 is not greater than or equal to 1895
12 5 but like what are these dates and
like why do we expect one to be greater
than the other and like what am I
supposed to do about it um and this is
especially hard if you know like if I
wrote this test yesterday I'll probably
be able to recover all of that context
but what if this this test hasn't failed
in two years or what if I've never seen
this test before because I'm new to this
team or what if I have 10 other failures
like this that need to be handled in
like special ways and so the information
I need to answer these questions isn't
really anywhere in this failure message
and so the question that we had for
ourselves
can we somehow use test failures to help
us recover context when they fail and
this is why we built marbles and before
I go any further I promise you it is
free and open source so everything I'm
about to talk about you can start
playing with it right now if you insist
but I think you should keep listening
so marbles is a again it's a it's a
Python unit test extension that gives
you really rich human readable failure
messages so I'm gonna it's they're
they're bigger than traditional unit
test failure messages so I'm gonna walk
through this step-by-step so the first
thing to notice is that there's no we
get the same like actual assertion error
as you see in a normal unit test failure
message but we've removed the trace back
and the reason that we did that is that
a marbles failure message as you'll see
it's gonna contain all of the
information you wouldn't normally find
in a traceback but it presents it in a
more consumable way so we can take that
trace back out without losing any
information if you miss the trace back
if you love the trace back and want to
see the trace back it is possible to run
your tests in verbose mode and you'll
get that trace back back the second part
and this is very this is similar to PI
test is that we'll pull out the line of
code and the surrounding lines of code
for the actual assertion statement
inside of your unit test that failed and
so this is helpful because you know
Python trace back it only gives you the
last line of the assertion that failed
so if the statement spans multiple lines
this can be really confusing so you you
wind up having to pop open the test code
to actually figure out what's going on
so to help you with that we grab the
whole statement like all of the lines
included in the statement that failed
next we pull out any public local
variables that are defined in your test
at the time it failed and so this is
really helpful because when I'm looking
at when I'm looking at the source and I
see this earliest birth date I'm like
okay well what what is that like what is
the value of that earliest birth date
and so this local section is really
helpful because it helps you recover
the state of the world at the time that
your test failed without you know
opening the test code and putting like
print or debugging statements everywhere
and like rerunning the tests and then
finally we make it possible for test
authors to annotate their tests and this
is like a free-form text annotation and
this annotation can include like
whatever you as the test author want it
to include it could include like a set
of actions to take when this test fails
it could include a link to like a run
book that that has those steps to take
but where this annotation really shines
is to give some background in additional
context on why this test is here and why
it matters and what you're supposed to
do so information about the test authors
intent that really doesn't fit into the
test method name we're like doesn't fit
clearly into the assertion and so this
is the whole thing at the correct
opacity and we compare it to again our
normal our normal unit test failure
which just like has a lot it's a much
lower information profile so as we've
just seen out of the box like marbles
gives you better failure messages but it
also gives you a lot of control over
what's like actually included in that
error message and so the first is that
we provide a set of really rich like
semantically rich assertion methods for
things that we commonly want to express
about data so things about betweenness
and uniqueness and and files and the
thing that's cool about this is like
when you pull out the source code like
that and you're presenting the assertion
to the test consumer it becomes
worthwhile to be really explicit and
really clear about what your assumption
is and this is closer to plain English
then that just like the bear assert
keyword or like assert true you can also
write your own assertion methods so you
can look at you can look at the source
code behind the assertion
we wrote to see how we do this if you
write something like let's say you make
a bunch of assertions about colors or
about temperatures that you think like
the rest of the the data community might
find useful we would really love to see
a pull request from you and the thing
that's the really cool thing that you
can do with this sort of inside your
organization is you can develop a set of
like a set of assertions that are
specific to your business that are now
you can make sure are being asserted in
exactly the same way across all of your
data teams you can also control which
variables show up in that local section
really easily just by making them public
or private so you can you as the test
author can start to curate okay like
what information what locals do I think
are going to be helpful for my test
consumer and sorry
those those note annotations are format
strings so you can make references to
local variables in your test and they'll
be expanded when your tests fail so this
lets you write really detailed really
specific advice that's based on the
state of the world when your test fails
they're similar to F strings in Python
three six in that you don't have to call
the format method yourself but they
differ and that these annotations will
only be expanded if and when your test
fails so how does this help us when
we're testing data so showing the source
helps sort of jog your memory and it
helps you recognize and remember a test
like when you're looking at a trace back
there's nothing really personal or
[Music]
there's nothing really to hold on to in
a trace back but like when I show you
the source you're like oh like that is
obviously a line of code like that's
maybe even a line of code that I wrote
and then I now remember writing and the
these like rich like these semantically
rich assertion methods make it a lot
clearer about okay what is actually the
predicate like being tested in this test
I
very much prefer the assertion methods
that are available in in in unit tests
to PI tests just using the assert
keyword there are a lot more expressive
and it makes the it makes the failures
just like that much easier to sort of
reverse engineer again the locals help
us really quickly recover the state of
the world the reason this is especially
important when you're writing unit tests
for data is that again the data that
you're testing could have been changed
by an upstream process that's totally
opaque to you so you might have no idea
what these data values are so showing
them in the failure is especially
helpful and again we can get access to
these without putting print or debugging
statements all over our code and finally
the notes communicate the author's sort
of intent and knowledge when and where
you need it most which is when your test
fails and this information stays
up-to-date because it's like embedded
right in the test and so really what we
did is is marbles takes a traditional
unit test and it treats that failure
message as documentation so that and
we're hoping our hope is that when you
start to think about test failures as
documentation for test consumers will
write clearer and more explicit tests
which are going to help us test more
things like data it turns out that these
failure messages are also really great
for just traditional software unit tests
so marbles will work perfectly with any
unit test tests you have today so you
can get these rich messages out of your
existing unit tests without changing any
code in two steps just pip install
marbles and then run your existing unit
tests and you'll see the marbles failure
messages so again it's a completely free
and open-source tool um please visit us
on github you can look at the source
code also take a look at the mix-ins and
and start thinking about some of your
own that you might want to use
and also the the docks are on on read
the ducks that we'll get into more about
how to really take advantage and take
advantage of the failure messages and
the cool things that you can do with it
to really help the test consumer out
thank you so much I like this too but I
found something interesting in our
semester the the function naming is in
in not in your pison way it's yeah just
like so this is a unit test this is a
unit testing and it's incredibly
frustrating and we had it made it was
very upsetting so in unit test the
assertion methods are camel cased as
opposed to snake cased and I don't have
I have an idea about why I think they
did this so that's so that's like a unit
like a like a Python unit test decision
in our mix-ins we decided to be
consistent with that we had a long
debate about it I I don't know why
exactly if someone here does I'm like
please can I tell you what I think the
answer is okay so I think the the one of
the things that it does is it helps you
distinguish between the assertion method
like distinguish the assert method from
other methods on the test case but okay
all right it's copied from j-unit that's
not a good enough reason and except or
searching to consider in the importing
like warning I don't know like warning
lever sorority like oh I see I see
um so I think I understand your question
it's like do we distinguish between like
critical and non-critical failures no so
we've thought about this
a lot and we and we haven't but what you
can do is that there's it's possible and
units has to write what's called a sub
test routine and so like inside a single
test method multiple assertions will be
made and it won't just fail on the first
one that fails but it will go through
and sort them all and so what you can do
is you can say okay here are my severity
levels and you can adjust that note
annotation and then you can sort of
going from like the most severe to least
severe or least severe to most severe
sort of make your assertions and
depending on how severe the failure is
that and it you can change that
annotation so it could say like oh my
god this is really bad
in all caps or you'll be like wait a
week okay thanks it's nice yep so how
when do you decide when to run this so
like when I'm when I'm making changes in
testing code I just write a unit test
I'm gonna write some code I see things
fail and then I correct it but in this
case I might get new data overnight I
might not get new data overnight how do
you decide when to do this yeah so you
can write a test to make sure that you
got data overnight but so this so this
is this is this is challenging what
we've done is it depends on the kind of
it depends on the situation that you're
in it depends on how soon you need to
know about failures you could run you
could you know set up your test suite to
run it could run everyday it could run
every hour you could put it in something
like an air flow tag so when you're sort
of air flow tag senses that data have
been delivered to like your s3 bucket or
something it will then kick off the your
tests another place that you run another
place that you might consider writing
and running you know tests of data like
this is in your ETL development like
so if you're writing code that's like
manipulating data and let's say you're
doing like you're doing some refactoring
on an ETL and you want to make sure that
you know you haven't screwed up the data
in any way it's a useful complement to
unit tests of like the software itself
so that's another place that you might
consider but like without knowing more
about the like how data are arriving to
you it's hard for me to recommend make a
recommendation about like when to
schedule the thing to run yeah sure so
one other question that arises to me is
like most of the data that I deal with
is temporal in nature and so how do you
grama ties this to deal with like
different times so like it failed
yesterday but I don't want it to fail
for all time because I can't go back in
time and correct the data maybe yeah so
if you are going back in time and
correcting the data it's useful to like
run it again and have the failure clear
itself one of the things that I didn't
talk about is that we also implemented
assertion logging so every time an
assertion is made if you configure the
logger marbles will dump like a JSON
blob with a lot of information about
that assertion and so you can you can
use that information you can you know
push it to somewhere like elasticsearch
or you know wherever you want to put it
to and you can use it to say okay if I
see this exact same failure again
tomorrow just like don't bother me it's
something that you can do so you don't
catalog and store the failures relative
to like some particular time period you
just like the failures happen and then
you decide whether you want to deal with
it and then move on well so we so we
work with datasets that are on a lot of
different timescales so it's really
dataset specific what we decide to do I
know that's a really crappy answer
just curious how it will work in a
stream processing scenario hi Jane
thanks very much for the talk and
there's recently been a lot of talk
about fairness and algorithmic
decision-making and how we need to be
aware of biases in our data so I was
wondering if something if you had used
something like this to maybe discover
some biases in your data sets that you
weren't aware of you can even write a
unit test to discover bias well so again
the thing about a unit test is that the
there needs to be kind of an unambiguous
distinction between failure and success
and white what we found you know I've
written many many many many many tests
for data using marbles and I've found
ways of sort of taking these more vague
like less clear-cut assumptions that I
have about data and sort of translating
them down into a binary pass/fail the
thing that's hard about that is that you
lose some information about what my
original like assumption was but I think
for the kind of for the kind of scenario
that you're talking about that really
comes out more in like the data
exploration and analysis and like
onboarding phase I think and not
something you would you know sort of
like oh like we've been getting this
test for you know months and months and
months and months and months and now we
think it's biased I can't really I would
have to think a lot harder about how I
might how I might use this to catch that
sort of thing
guess one last question for the day hi
I'm kind of working in a similar
environment not as being we have like a
huge dashboard like with green and red
dots but that stops functioning yes if
you have thousands how do you guys do
that so how do we keep track of all
these failures uh I unfortunately cannot
answer this particular question in a lot
of detail but we do take we do take data
stewardship like very seriously so there
we just we do not want to be in a
situation where we have datasets that no
one sort of understands deeply and like
knows about in terms of presentation
it's just you got to work with your UX
people about how to how to consume ibly
how to sort of present that information
in a consumable way that in a way that
doesn't like scare people
too much scares them the right amount
you want just like the right amount of
read I will say like if your dashboard
is entirely green like you're not
ingesting any data that never happens
you got a bigger problem
and so you need also if you find errors
you get a whole catalog of hope to call
back and what to do like we have a lot
of problems we don't want to bother the
developers anymore with common crashes
so we have this whole process now of
people like moderating it and then
sending follow-up emails and hey guys
your data is [ __ ] oh yeah yeah yeah I
mean what you could say is like hey like
you should we need you to put we keep
emailing you about this we need you to
be catching this and responding to it
yourselves like and here and if it's the
kind of situation where they were you
where they're not remembering what to do
the like they're not catching it and
they also like keep forgetting what
they're supposed to do this is actually
this is like a really good tool for that
because you
like look I'm gonna tell you this once
throw it in that annotation and then
whoever's on your team is gonna see that
and then you can put your email at the
end of it and be like okay where's comes
to worse you can email me and I'll tell
you what to do but yeah you can you can
use it you can use it to solve a lot of
these kind of like tricky organizational
conflicts because you you don't have any
excuses anymore people run out of
excuses thank you so much
[Applause]